- [Interviewer] All right.
- All right.
- All right, Baby.
- Yes?
- [Interviewer] Baby, how
far along are you now?
- I'm, well, almost nine months.
Eight months, probably
eight months and a week?
I probably got like three,
three to four weeks left.
- [Interviewer] And this is,
you're still living on the street?
- Yeah, I'm still living on, in a tent,
well, not even in a tent,
basically, on the street
in and out of different peoples' tents.
- [Interviewer] And what's your plan here?
You're having a baby soon?
- Well, I was hoping to get an apartment,
but I guess my plan for
now is to go back to Vegas,
and see what I can get out there.
- [Interviewer] And what's in Vegas?
- Just more familiar with the
surroundings and the people
and more comfortable out
there than I am out here
being around them, I guess.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have friends or anything?
- I wouldn't call 'em friends,
but I just been out there for four years,
so yeah, I'm more comfortable
around all those people,
and I know that area a
lot better than out here.
- [Interviewer] Right, do you suppose,
you stopped using you're telling me?
- Yeah, like I said I did take
some mushrooms last night,
but I didn't take like, like two little,
you know what I'm saying,
little pieces of mushrooms, so--
- [Interviewer] But
crystal meth is no longer?
- No crystal meth, I
haven't used that since,
actually, I used twice after
I had that first interview
with you, you know like,
no, I haven't since then.
So, it's probably two months
after I had my interview
was the last time I used crystal meth.
- [Interviewer] And what's
the chances of you using
when you get to Vegas,
you will be living on the street there?
- At first I will be, but
I'm pretty comfortable
and pretty confident now that I won't,
you know, just turn to using when I get,
you know what I'm saying,
to the point I have nothing
or all else fails, I feel
like I can just, it's,
the baby's almost here.
I feel like I can make it.
At least if I needed to use,
I could make it until after
that, being responsible.
- [Interviewer] How are
you gonna support yourself?
- I'm gonna try and,
out there I can get copy of
my old ID, my Tennessee ID,
and with that, I can at
least go and get a voucher
to get a real ID for California.
I mean, for Nevada.
Whereas out here, I
don't have none of that.
- [Interviewer] And what will you do?
- Hopefully, I'll just go to,
at first, my plan is to
go to like a temp service,
and just you know, day by
day, see if they got work
until I can get in like
a program or something
and get referred to like a,
I really wanna go back to college
and open up my own business.
But that'll take more time, so,
right now, it's basically temp service
is my main goal right
now after I get my ID.
See how that goes, you know?
- [Interviewer] And so,
you're gonna keep the baby?
- [Baby] Yeah, I do plan
on keeping the baby.
I do. I really wanna have my baby at home.
I wanna get like a midwife or something.
- [Interviewer] What about
going back to Tennessee,
do you have anybody--
- [Baby] I would love to go
back to Tennessee eventually,
but it's way worse out there,
like if I go back to Tennessee,
I'm more likely to just
automatically turn to drugs
because I really, that's where I'm from,
that's where my family's from,
but they basically have
nothing to do with me
except for the fact that they
take care of my daughter,
which I don't think, you
know what I'm saying,
it's not, it's not a city,
it's all country out there, I wouldn't--
- [Interviewer] There's
lots of drugs there, too?
- I was cooking meth in Vegas growing up,
I mean, in Tennessee, I'd probably,
that's a whole 'nother
addiction in itself,
which of course comes along with using.
And then, I think I'd be more likely
to just turn back to
drugs going to Tennessee,
especially being that close to my daughter
and not being able to have her, too.
- [Interviewer] And there's a chance
of you losing the baby, too, right?
- Right, if I did, yes, I did.
I don't, the last thing
I want is to lose my baby
after I went through all this,
you know what I'm saying,
just to have him, even though
I have used a few times.
Nobody's perfect, you know?
I just, I don't wanna,
that's not what I wanna do,
but I can't say that I'm
not gonna use in time.
I be going through a lot.
I'll be stressed out.
I can't say that's not
gonna be a first resort
in the future.
If it is, it is. If it's not, it's not.
I don't want it to be, but--
- [Interviewer] Did, were you,
how did you get pregnant
in the first place?
Were you thinking this
was a good thing to do?
- No, actually, it was a one-night stand.
I just, this dude walked
past me on The Strip in Vegas
and said some weird freaky stuff,
and I just wanted to
know what it was about.
So I called him, and we had sex one night,
and I got pregnant.
I don't really even know the man.
Actually he's in prison,
federal prison in Vegas,
and I barely knew his name
until he called me from prison.
- [Interviewer] Did you tell
him he's got a kid coming?
- Yeah, he knew before.
He found out like two months
before he went to prison,
and then, he went to prison,
and I talked to him twice.
And I haven't talked to him since then.
And this was like, I was probably
three or four months pregnant then.
So that was the last time I talked to him.
But he does know.
As far as I knew then,
he wanted something to do with it,
but I haven't spoken to him since then
or heard anything since
then, so I don't really know.
All I know is that he's
supposed to get out in November,
which is soon, but we'll see what happens.
I just gotta wait on him
to hit me up on Facebook.
- [Interviewer] Hm.
I don't even know what to
say. I don't even know.
- It's crazy. Shit's been crazy.
- [Interviewer] I just
feel for your baby to come.
- Yeah, I feel, I feel, too.
And honestly I don't even have
anything for the baby yet,
like I'm not ready, I'm really not.
But I'm ready to do it,
I guess, day by day,
you know what I'm saying?
Like it's just--
- [Interviewer] Tell me your
thoughts on birth control,
I mean, don't you think--
- On birth control?
- [Interviewer] Maybe if
you were, if you were--
- I was on the Depo when I was younger,
but it did make me gain a lot of weight.
Honestly, I'm not a big fan
of doctors or hospitals,
so I don't know about birth control,
you know what I'm saying?
'Cause you gotta go see
the doctor for that shit.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, but then
having sex with strangers--
- I mean, no, no, it wasn't,
that's not something that always happens.
It was just like, okay,
I hear stuff everyday
from, you know, men walking past
and I just kinda ignore it.
But the man said something,
I'ma tell you what he said,
he said, "I wanna tongue
fuck your booty hole."
And it caught my attention, so
I was like, "What'd you say?"
You know what I'm saying,
I had to turn around
and walk back to him,
and ask him, like,
"Excuse me, sir, I just needed to know
"what you said to me?"
And when he repeated it,
I was like, oh yeah, I need
to know you're talking about,
you know what I'm saying?
But hey, yeah, that's not just something,
I don't, I don't even like,
sex is not a thing for me really.
But just so happen--
- There you go.
- That one time,
and this is what happened.
- All right, Baby, well,
thank you for coming in
and giving us an update.
I wish you the very best.
- Thank you.
- I hope something miraculous
happens in your life and
saves your baby from--
- Thanks.
- From a tough life.
- Man, it's gonna be tough regardless,
but you know, I just hope
that it's life-changing
and for the better, ya know?
- [Interviewer] Mm-hmm, you need that.
I'm gonna help you get
closer to Vegas at least.
- Yeah, thank you for interviewing me.
It's nice to talk to you again.
- [Interviewer] You look healthy.
- [Baby] Thank you.
I feel like fucking Shamu the
whale or something right now.
People keep telling me
like, you're so fat,
you gained a lot of weight
in the last, you know, month.
Yeah, I'm ready. I'm ready.
I told somebody I'm ready
to have this baby Thursday,
I'm pushing.
- All right. Well, good luck.
- All right.
- Bye.